[Music]
she's sorry
[Music]
this fall
six cities
prepare
for two
rebels with a cause
[Music]
phoenix
houston
charleston nashville new york
baltimore
[Applause]
the rebels with a cars comedy tour
tickets on sale now at
louderwithcrowder.com
tour
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's june which marks louder with
crowder's seventh annual cultural
appropriation month where we take you
across the globe
learning about and appreciating all the
diverse cultures this planet has to
offer
[Music]
this week it is our pleasure to take you
on a life-changing journey to the
productive land of pineapple cakes
the ping sky lantern festival and john
cena is the prototype himself john cena
ladies and gentlemen no way
[Music]
honduran
is where she went freestyle rape
[Music]
pretty fun place like i think
i'm in a fun place i think i'm right
here
in a fun place
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what does this
mean i believe it means you can't see
him but you can i know you can you just
keep moving your hand fast enough you
can see between the hand what no just do
this you know what just kick him in the
groin you know what else is my shoulder
is it has a lactic acid buildup
that's why he has shoulders that are a
great way to shut the show with
rhabdomyolysis there you go a little
smoke-filled room yeah look we all hate
john cena
love even though he's all natural
i did my own research on this
there's no real origin story to this
there's none it just started one day
well you look at one one source says
this means my moves are so fast you
won't see them coming but then i read an
interview with john cena he just said i
was listening to g-unit
like a
douche his brother said you look stupid
he was like y'all do this on air bro he
was like i bet you won't he was like i
bet i will and then
really that's the story this is the
world we live in that's popular wow dude
exactly somebody's like he's his own
next make-a-wish yes
can we see ronald mcsina house
[Laughter]
this is he just has to be just bald well
john cena has progeria so
well johnny all right we have a lot to
get to today of course it's cultural
appropriation month taiwan you send in
your costumes we will be taking the
winners on mug club
we'll be talking about a lot here today
uh i don't know if you know about this
it just so happens to coincide china has
a new military decree
which involves taiwan which involves all
of your chip sets eileen goo remember
that uh
that broad who she she decided to ski
for china
well now she wants to ski for the united
states again what no there's open border
policies now that are real look you were
mad about 40 million to the ukraine 40
billion sorry we really met about the
350 million to house refugees in other
countries
oh that's good yeah and then this is
something i really wanted to talk about
the uh you know you have the fed just
increased interest rates um do you
expect another housing crash
a lot of people have been asking it's
not going to look like 2008
but there is going to be a correction we
definitely have some issues that we're
running into also uh tim the tool man or
casey can turn on the cigar fan because
boy
it is not healthy to breathe
you guys can comment below if you see
another housing crash coming up and
here we have him fastest man on his feet
gonna be with me lightweight.com tour
fall tour phoenix
houston
charleston west virginia nashville red
bank because new york city wouldn't have
us and then uh baltimore
which by the way tickets are on sale in
baltimore we got a lot of people
complaining they weren't available until
last oh yeah yeah they saw that didn't
get them going how are you doing there
dave ahoy i'm good good i'm cywin yang
yes david foster wallace yes
i own a lesbian bookstore that only
sells virginia woolf yes
and host drag queen story yes indeed
incredibly popular one sit around then
we have gerald here the best man how are
you sir i am well other than not being
accepted to harvard because i'm asian
that's it that's it really phoning that
one in costume why is your harvard shirt
like a toga
he didn't have to wear it like that no
he didn't he chose to wear it like we
watched him take the sleeves off that's
just because we wouldn't allow him to
wear it tied up like david allen grier
yeah we're like we have to read the
harvard it's better for airflow and then
we've got uh we've got well we've got
hazmat suit we've got oh casey is ang
lee's
aang lee's the hulk
because he's taiwanese
yes yes not a stretch at all yeah not a
stretch there's only so much in taiwan
it's an island
and then uh well together is just
something is are you raiden pineapple
i hope your costumes are better folks
hurting his father
but it is cultural appropriation month
and two appropriate is to appreciate so
we always want to teach you right every
cultural appropriation month every
thursday yeah uh so it's uh time to get
some key facts regarding taiwan
[Laughter]
i wonder what he was saying it sounded
pretty by the way that's their top 1
through 40. it's all oh yeah it's just
one song what's number two
what's number four
heinz there's subtle differences they're
on the top give me an extra hundred yes
all right so uh we have to decide if
these are fact or fiction because we
realized some of you folks weren't
paying attention to the cultural
appropriation month fact so token one
let's uh give us some and some of these
are real some of these are not right and
yeah that's that's you and gerald your
job is to figure out which ones are
which not dave because he helped us
write these oh okay
well that's good when it comes to facts
i was gonna i was gonna be good at this
then
why did you do this all right give it
give it to us token on taiwan okay so
first off we got one six of all screws
are made in taiwan
um okay you want us to guess what to
guess yeah in real time that's a fact
yeah okay i don't think so no no i don't
think that's a fact what is it
the answer is
fact oh come here you go it's a fact all
right
okay give us fact number two yeah see i
knew that all right number two the most
common surname in taiwan is dong no that
can't be a fact that's racist that's got
to be true
no true what's the answer
stephen is right oh yeah it's not dung
it's actually chen yep we just have
racist writers dong is actually number
two also racist
dong is actually the currency name in uh
in vietnam really that's 100 true wow
the dongs i had a lot of dongs when i
was over that sounds terrible why did i
say that the vietnam's are coming
money
crap millions of dongs
this is guerrilla warfare they're the
largest dong they've ever seen 100 000
notes if you don't give me five billion
dongs
uh sorry
it's the dong show i don't think that's
just that's just pornography all right
give us another one token now number
three no taiwanese believe that john
cena is in fact real i'm gonna say
that's true that's because that's more
reciprocity no i'm going opposite all
right
real not true that is not true yeah all
right
all tied up well that's more of an
assumption yes i mean it could be true
it's how they feel but it may not be
dead german also can't do math because
if we're not tied up those questions
stephen math we are all tied up nope
steven's in the lead right yeah i'm in
the lead all right two to one all right
number four we got taiwanese
superstition holds that if students trim
their nails during their final exams
they will end up with failing grades for
their subjects no no that's a
misinterpretation of samson it was hair
100 true
don't trim your nails the answer is
true oh true
well you know what maybe china should
take them over
all right now now we're all tied up oh
no i trim my nail let me i'll get b plus
yeah that's why you failed it's a lot of
drinking the night before yes
[Laughter]
all right number five taiwanese nails
will come in handy when they're
scratching at the prison door from the
chinese invasion there you go i feel
like they're not drunks like frat boys
here no probably not doing sake shots
all night they're not trimming their
nails
yeah all right all right number five
taiwan was traditionally known in the
west as formosa
jailed true true
well he said are you awake
we're both
i didn't hear you you said true i did
say true you guys both no one he doesn't
listen to me you guys say it at the same
time he listens you listen to me so
little i should marry you all right
let's go to the next his ears bleeding
hey uh that's it that's six right well
that was now we got one more there's one
more okay
go so final one snake alley is a market
in taipei that serves unique delicacies
such as snake blood turtle blood and
deer penis wine well that just seems so
odd that it must be true it is
absolutely false there is no such thing
as deer penis wine i don't know you
don't know that
even if this isn't true you don't know
that give us the answer all right this
answer also declares the winner
because you guys are tied up and it is
stephen that was true oh come on gerald
i've
i've seen you drinking deer penis wine
yeah he's even identified the vintage
yeah i've seen you taking it right from
the tap yeah i go i go what's your
favorite year it goes all of them yes
i was like is this carl carl it's like
what's the varietal i just love it that
doesn't matter i know you can't get
enough of it all right that's been
taiwan facts
[Music]
i love it every time i hear it do you
think we're what's the bet on are we
still on youtube
we just played their music what do you
mean
we're still on youtube all right so
there you go i don't know if china minds
us doing taiwan no we don't quote the
cdc well don't worry we're going to get
to trashing china in just a minute
because i don't know if you know this i
don't want to vilify an entire nation of
people but china is a horrible place yes
and uh it's a live show monday through
thursday 10 a.m eastern so we're on
rumble and we are on mug club if you do
not see us here on youtube i have no
idea how long we'll be on youtube of
course we're gone july taping some other
things we always have to take this break
and rebuild the studio up but unless we
tell you we're not here that means we're
on rumble or over there on the mud club
so uh let me bring you some news here on
on
taiwan and china and then gerald is
really passionate about it so uh let me
set this up so chairman xi xingping you
know who that is yeah that guy yeah
winnie the pooh
yep now we're done
i was just waiting to hear the sound of
rockets we're good if there was a
missile
so we just signed a decree uh that would
allow for the deployment of chinese
troops for purposes
other than war uh as zoltan knew
they needed to tell that to all the
muslim uyghurs no no no they're not
using war powers no it's different
flying round when your everyday powers
are just as heinous as your war powers
at this point we're splitting
we're splitting very straight black
hairs folks yes
so the media the state media uh xinhua
you'd cut to me
[Laughter]
so this new outline aims to quote
protect people's
i guess i should i have to protect
people's lives and property safeguard
national sovereignty security and
develop interest and safeguard world
peace and regional stability because
when i think china i think
world peace yeah is this a beauty
pageant world peace stability yeah
stability like beating you yes arresting
you why do you need a decree for this
stuff
i'm not really sure that's a good
question
probably because they're lying ah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah but they want us to
not think that they're lying well sort
of like john cena
yeah i hate myself today you realize
this makes me depressed wearing this
that this is the current state of
wrestling so let me ask you today it
looks good on you yeah i think this
should be in every day
[Laughter]
no sorry
well you know what i can't believe that
i'm only like he's there's only a
20-pound weight difference between me
and john cena how is that possible he
looks like a different species he's four
foot nine oh okay yeah
he's really short that's why people
can't see him they look right there they
love them in chat oh yeah not deduced to
the gills yeah no of course not no he's
natural so let me ask you before uh we
move into jail what do you think that
china means by safeguard safeguard world
peace i'm doing the half asian accent
safeguard but i mean safeguard world
peace what do you think that actually
what is
what's that sound what is that noise i
wish i knew how to quit you
oh yeah oh my gosh
he's kind of known for one thing
yeah
gay cowboys not time all right he did
make that movie it is time though for
gerald no stuff
now let me set this up you guys should
go and watch if we're on youtube we can
put a card up here go and watch we did a
very long forum segment on taiwan on
what a war between china and taiwan
would look like it would have to take
place during really one of two months
during the year why it would affect you
why it's different from ukraine because
of the chip sets of course uh which
we're dependent on taiwan for so screws
i had no idea screws yeah yes what are
we gonna do deck screws gosh we're gonna
pressure fit everything now
so gerald's intro guys if you're
listening dear penis wine needs to be
added yeah it does it needs to be in
there
dear d-e-e-r no yes no not dear penis
[Laughter]
that's a nickname but he'd be writing a
letter to himself
is that a dear me country song your
penis so your rights in his diary if you
want the geo the sort of geopolitical
situation there specifically as far as
what that war would look like how it
affects you why it's different from
ukraine i would recommend you go and
watch that it was a very long i think we
did a whole show on it we did we did a
debate on it as well about ukraine so
about ukraine so this is a little bit
different because of the new changes i
want to tell you something before gerald
goes in here uh after seeing the
taiwanese uh train with airsoft guns
because their own citizens aren't
allowed to have
assault weapons
i'm less i'm less pro protecting them
i'll get to that it did frustrate you it
frustrated me beyond recognition what
does it take what does it take
you basically you are a nation
effectively who are founded upon the
idea that this other giant wants to wipe
you out and you you still don't let your
citizens have still don't let your
citizens have military style weapons
they should all be forced to train in
them and have a couple in their closet
it should be like a switzerland
situation you know world war ii with all
their military age men but instead
unfortunately this is one thing you guys
need to get straight taiwan okay i
understand it's a much more important
partnership uh for us than for example
ukraine but if you think that let's say
china were to try and wipe taiwan off
the face of the map and everyone from
taiwan is going to come in the united
states and they're going to be
pro-america you still will be looking at
a demographic of people who want to be
subjugated by their government there is
no spirit of rugged individualism of
individual liberty outside of the united
states so i'm i'm under no ill-conceived
notions that the taiwanese are actually
pro-america in the way that we would
believe it to be you don't allow your
citizens the right to train with if
there is a nation that should be
training
with with military-style assault weapons
let's use i mean assault rifles actual
military assault rifles not ar-15s i
mean actually automatic yeah yes m16s
burst fires or gatling guns for all you
all you know they should be doing it
that gives you an idea the left will
never concede that territory if canada
had the same population as the united
states and they were trying to invade
the usa
the left still wouldn't say you know
what hey maybe you should have the right
to defend your house and home there will
never be a scenario under which they
believe you have the right to defend
yourself for reference see every other
country in the history of the world okay
yeah well and and to be clear in taiwan
you can own a shotgun a rifle and a
handgun but we were talking i was like
is there any other clear example in the
world where you want to make sure
everybody knows how to use assault
weapons if that you know that military
weapons like let's get everybody tank
training how about that right let's go
as far as we can but they see a lot of
similarities and we've talked about this
like you said between the russia
invasion and not only the invasion of
ukraine and how the world responded to
it but what russia did specifically
vladimir putin in the lead-up to that
issuing this decree and so i saw this on
i think mondays when it came out and it
went into effect yesterday and i was
like this is a really weird way to frame
this entire thing like you release a
decree that basically gives you power to
go wherever you want and do whatever you
want and say oh it's not a military
operation we're preserving world peace
we're defending citizens we're taking
care of our national sovereignty right
and they still consider taiwan a part of
them so that makes sense so eugene kuala
an analyst with taiwan's institute for
national policy research said i think
it's definitely a copy of putin's
special operation language and that was
the decree that he issued was a it's not
war it's a special operation like you
didn't put any thought into this right
like what were you like two seconds
before going on camera what's the name
special operation i'm not a warmonger
i'm a war stylist
yeah and continuing his quote and after
what happened in ukraine it sends a very
threatening signal to taiwan japan and
the surrounding countries in the south
china sea so
kwa believes that xi is trying to
enhance gray zone activities which is
basically like saying we don't we don't
recognize international borders
international waters right we think that
this is our territory so it's like these
are kind of acts of war that are not
acts of war and so they're kind of like
pushing and poking the bear a little bit
here so that's what we don't recognize
them we don't recognize them as
international waters but they are ah
well now everybody's inviting says oh
okay yeah sorry about that
my bad it's like the strait of taiwan
it's like hey there's international
waters here i think usually every
country i think it's 12 miles out right
that you can claim is kind of national
waters outside of that it's
international waters and they're like no
we don't really play by everybody else's
rule so that's what he's talking about
there so they're worried right so
taiwan is also taking note of china's
moves here right down a little bit down
below there
so on wednesday taiwan's foreign
minister joseph wu spoke on china's
increasing escalation we have a little
bit we have a clip yes right now from
what we see recently uh china seems to
be uh gearing up it's a military prize
negotiations and i can give you some
evidences of this
in the first part of may uh china has
uh conducted naval exercises east of
taiwan uh for two weeks with his
aircraft strike group leoning
and they have also conducted air
exercises around taiwan especially in
southern part
adiz
and in several occasions they also
crossed the medium line of the taiwan
strait which has been safeguarding
status quo and peace and stability over
this area for years and moreover their
spokesperson for the uh
pla has spoken about uh the medium line
of the town strait does not exist
because taiwan is part of china
and very recently their ministry of
foreign affairs spokesperson also talked
about taiwan as part of china and
therefore the taiwan strait is not an
international water so if we put all
this together we see a very threatening
china these days here before you move on
really quickly i just when you for those
who are listening on audio you saw that
map where you just look at how huge huge
china is yeah now small taiwanese now
that being said there's a reason that
there hasn't been a land invasion
because of course china wants to take
that one they've been saying it there is
something that they're scared of in this
you can go to the previous uh
show video it might be on crowder bits
but certainly the full show where we've
talked about what that looks like the
mountainous terrain how taiwan is
actually you know punching above their
weight class that being said this should
also give you an idea
when we're talking about the second
amendment you have people who will make
these arguments going oh well what you
think american you think american gun
owners have a chance against the united
states military if it comes yes
absolutely there are over there are more
guns in this country than there are
citizens the number i don't know if it's
between 350 million or over 400 million
dollars depends on what the updated
number is and we have 300 something
million people here in this country 40
something percent of households own a
firearm you think about what's going on
in taiwan i'll show you their airsoft
training in a second which is absolutely
embarrassing and laughable they should
be ashamed of themselves but the united
states
yeah because we we have we have have you
ever been to the south do you know the
rednecks that we have here oh yeah well
i mean you're also assuming that when
you look at like the military they're
here to protect the country right not
the government from taking us over right
like the whole military would just go
with them no it wouldn't happen i'm just
saying that if they had in taiwan what
we have here it would just be a bunch of
ar-15 round casings and and natty ice
can that would be sticking have you gone
to like you go to the range
on the weekend yeah and they and they're
they're you're like that guy's drunk and
he's hitting everything yeah he's
hitting everything you just have some
400 pound mother with an uzi just a taco
bell bag these people yes they could
defend themselves against a land
invasion it certainly would help yeah
absolutely crystal burger aka yes
well no you're 100 right with the
numbers thing of course we would do
better i mean what did russia do they
basically gave their soldiers a gun when
the guy in front of you gets killed they
gave the guy behind him ammunition so
that he could pick up the guy's gun that
was killed put the ammunition in and
continue fighting that was that was
literally what they did i believe it was
stalingrad when they were defending it i
can't remember the name but anyway
monday taiwan has to respond right so
monday this decree comes out and it's
obviously like aimed at taiwan even
though they're not saying it is and
their legislative speaker yun fong came
out and said uh that and i this isn't
much of a like threat to them we have
missiles that are capable to attack a
beijing and i'm like that's like texas
saying they can hit louisiana that's not
exactly technological maybe texas should
hit louisiana well i'm just saying it's
not like saying we're firing them
crawfish is ours [ __ ] we don't want
it i want the boutique
toufee whatever the hell that is and
keep it yeah no okay so that's that's
not much of a threat
sorry i love how much you hate being
john cena just your body language
it's like putting a christmas sweater on
a bulldog
when i was a kid you know we had we had
the undertaker before it was before was
just a biker they said hey let's take an
interesting character we have the
undertaker favorite ever yeah but back
in the day i mean i guess they brought
him back to that character they said
let's just put everyone in jorts in
t-shirts you think about the ultimate
warrior you think about hulk hogan you
think about uh gold dust do you think
about triple h before he was triple h
when he was hunter herself there was buy
and this is a t this is just dressing
like an [ __ ]
i have a douchebag character that
everybody will hate like when you got in
that i i it's just your mood change
and you're right that's the thing you're
100 right i can't get out of it fast
enough well
i'd rather be dressed as a chick
honestly we could burn i think i think
this would be a better wrestler
just show up and hit you with late fees
i'd rather be anglies whatever you are
over makes you use bing yeah she's
bringing out the book
time to be quiet in her library oh geez
all right so look the the invasion of
ukraine has definitely got uh people in
taiwan kind of rethinking your sidekick
is just a little bent back paper clip
from work
i'm sorry i hate you i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry i know you're really i know
you're really good you you you really
care about these things you just hit him
with the dewey decimal system
round i want you to give me pie
all the way to the 42nd digit no oh no
all right this is somehow better
than john cena
look at these look at these look at
these
hustle loyalty respect that's his slogan
yeah that's it's reminding him to do
this because this makes him sweat so
much yeah his slogan is oprah's book
club it's just
however you can make more money that's
exactly apologies i'm sorry all that all
those useless muscles and he's an
absolute spineless pansy cow towing to
china because overlords this is the
thing about this industry guys let me
tell you something before we go on with
china you wonder doesn't this guy have
fu money my dad was just asking that
it's that you owe somebody something
john cena is owned by other people and i
don't mean there's some secret
bilderberg meeting i mean that guy even
if he does think that taiwan has the
right to exist can't say it that's what
when you wonder how can so many people
in the entertainment industry get
together and all have the same opinion
you would even think just by
happenstance there might be some
divergence it's because you owe you owe
someone in the industry and john cena
[ __ ] go ahead
absolutely right well so i mean
obviously this this is one of the
reasons that i care about it it's
because china is exerting force over the
entire world right now because we've
we've outsourced factories to them we've
we've kind of cow towered right because
they're a big financial powerhouse and
now they're making threats against a
country that should be independent in
taiwan and taiwan is making some you
know they're having like a real come to
jesus moment here knowing that this
could happen really quickly and they're
they're increasing their training with
reservists reservists and everything
else so there's a quote from one of the
reservists nearly every day my
commanders would remind the men that the
threat from china was growing it's like
like you needed to say that yeah ukraine
don't let them don't let them own
assault weapons though right don't let
them train with the things they will
actually need to defend their country uh
ukraine showed us another part of the
quote that you need to first show to
others that you have the resolve to
defend yourself only then while others
come to your help and that is true and i
appreciate that they understand that
they have to stay and fight this is not
our country
you guys if you're not willing to fight
like we fought for our country right why
should we come over and help you guys
because it's just gonna be us doing it
leaving in the same situation may be
occurring again so it doesn't really
solve anything um civilians though this
is the favorite part for mad john cena
over here civilians have also started
participating in this makes me not want
to help taiwan simulated i've almost
done a 180 in my position show the clip
you'll see why
god first comment is that airsoft
yes
why is casey shooting guns yes
[Music]
how to save ammo
yeah that's how you want the fun of your
country
finley sleeve tattoos and a willard
haircut
there's a reason there's a reason to
make your buzz cut here
[Applause]
for those listening on audio and by the
way you can subscribe on apple and
android and spotify and i recommend you
do there's some content sometimes that
you get there that you don't get here on
youtube or rumble uh they're talking
about training up effectively as militia
reservists right this should this should
sort of answer a couple of questions for
you when people here argue hey what part
of your ass is a part of a regulated
militia everyone you see those are just
people here in the united states people
can get together and become any kind of
a militia the militia is the whole
people that's what mason said they were
very very clear militia by the way
legally was defined as any able-bodied
men capable of serving back then capable
of protecting their country so you see
this now when push comes to shove there
you go that's a militia those aren't
people with military haircuts those are
people with largely their own equipment
in many cases and they're using airsoft
which we all know is yeah it's exactly
the same as firing an actual weapon yeah
except stop shooting me no way
whatsoever it doesn't even have like
kick to it right somehow they're moving
right yeah well that's just because
they're incredibly weak yeah yeah well
no i mean i i think i think you're
absolutely right recoil yes
recoil
recoil
it's too late in the game to be able to
think that you need weapons as you're
being attacked like oh crap i wish our
citizens had weapons don't you think
ukrainians right now wish that every
able-bodied man had military training be
able to defend themselves against russia
they're doing a decent job
but it would have it would have been
much money and look at that look look at
ukraine and russia look at what happened
with the taliban for crying out loud
guess what when you when you're fighting
on your own terrain when you know yeah
you're the locale where you'll be
fighting guess what you have a huge
advantage think about the home court
advantage in sports games you don't
think so in the hills of west virginia
you don't louisiana and the swamps of
louisiana in texas these people who live
here are going to know how to defend it
better than people who've never set foot
there are going to know how to attack it
that's that's absolutely true not to
mention the ability here to have
incredible firearms which we rightfully
should and i i'm not being facetious
a part of me would like to see if i were
president i would say okay uh taiwan
talks are off the table we will not help
you protect you unless you allow every
single citizen to uh
have firearms oh only shotguns or no you
allow them to have ar-15s you allow them
have uh high-capacity semi-automatic
rifles you know the kind of stuff that
you would need them to use uh during
wartime because don't come to us for
protection don't when you haven't when
you haven't maximized your own resources
and the most important resource as it
relates to any kind of amphibious war
that we might see with taiwan again you
can go back to a previous of it is going
to be the citizens and the citizens
ability there go the militia to protect
themselves i am so tired of the united
states
paying for the rest of the world and
hearing the rest of the world [ __ ]
about how we pay for it
we're talking about russia ukraine
sweden we want to be in nato now no hey
all i've heard you do is [ __ ] about for
years just talk down to the united
states if you had your socialized health
care system guess what pay for pay for
all of your socialized health care
systems and pay for all of your social
safety net [ __ ] okay pay for all of
it and back pay 2 of your gdp on
military spending for nato you know for
the last 60 years then we'll consider it
yeah while you were paying for
healthcare we were building a military
yes to make sure that we could defend
our own country and also help out a
number of nations throughout the last 60
years right and i obviously i think
taiwan is far more important than
ukraine i think that it would make sense
for the united states to protect them
but you know what they need to start
back in the day if we were to protect a
country like taiwan protect a place like
taiwan would be okay now you speak our
language and you pay taxes to us you
know if we were a king if we were a
monarchy you don't go in and help
another nation because you're dependent
on them for chip sets it's guess what
your chipsets are ours now we get a
commission because well why because you
wouldn't exist if not for us so it would
it would have been colonization yeah
which everyone here colonia which
everyone wants to [ __ ] about how do you
think the world works how do you think
the world works throughout his do you
think genghis khan was paying for other
nations to take in refugees he was
making refugees and killing them on the
way out
well that was rude it was pretty i
believe he did that yeah but he had a
lot of kids
he did that's true well hopefully
hopefully there's enough of a threat
with the citizens of taiwan japan and
the united states to keep china
from invading but here's the problem as
long as you have somebody weak in the
white house who has shown an inability
to act effectively ukraine and russia
it just gives them the green light they
know they can probably take japan they
know they can probably take taiwan right
if we're involved if the rest of the
world is involved that's a different
story the rest of the world needs to
step up the rest of the world need to
step up and we need we need to
disconnect ourselves from this idea of a
global economy we really do especially
we can get bin of a barrel by china for
it because that's the reason people
don't speak out when you said they're
owned what happens right now if the nba
speaks out on china what happens to
revenue for movies if they speak out on
china right now what happens to apple if
they speak out nike if they speak out
just name every industry right if they
speak out on china because we have said
for years we're just the ideas country
what happens what happens to what
happens to facebook twitter and youtube
if they don't throttle content that's
anti-chinese think about that for a
second one of their biggest emerging
markets right china says guess what
we're going to put a ban on your website
they don't want that this is the problem
it doesn't require some crazy conspiracy
theory a meeting right behind closed
doors of cabal it's just understanding
the chinese government understanding how
they censor understanding how they
pressure american businesses to kowtow
to their policies which by the way are
gross violations of human rights
that's all it takes yeah and that's why
john cena needs to get his ass kicked by
you know someone who's actually in the
mix you know someone who actually fights
uh but of course before be sure to drug
test uh me this has been gerald no stuff
anyway it's good to see the taiwanese
preparing but um
they could use better guns well either
way look it's great that they're taking
the threat seriously at the very least
yes
what's um
what's uh what's it's my studio now
oh hi john oh hey uh hey ping
how are you i heard your shoulder no
doing good oh no yeah the last time we
played golf
you know it's doing better still tweaked
i could send you a acupuncturist that
could do a fire cupping for you
fire
cupping fire cupping well yeah yeah you
know if you have a guy that helped
thanks anyway this studio will belong to
me now you will give it to me shut
up
i'll take care of this
[Music]
[Applause]
me how
[ __ ]
hey ty uh
he's a demigod the bazooka doesn't work
try the try the walls
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah it works you're all very welcome
good stuff yeah nice job welcome
appreciate that and of course uh walther
is the official firearm of the latter
crowder studios we are protected here by
uh walther and joe lewis um and i do
recommend you guys go check out the uh
the pdp we don't have one here actually
that was the old ppq yeah yeah there's a
pp maybe i need them to send me like a
prop pdp because it's like sorry i went
like it's my character
yeah let's go well it's not gone you
just can't see it
same same right i'm a magician yeah
david copperfield like making an old
buick disappear
oh that's all it takes
someone let his vegas budget know oh man
so uh this is one thing we're really
happy for them to be a sponsor the
perfect sponsor for this show is a
product that we all use anyway then we
reached out to them they saw that we use
them and they have the balls to sponsor
the show which many of you may not know
a lot of firearm manufacturers out there
don't do that they actually do work
alongside the gun control lobbyists
because they want to uh you know
eliminate competition so you can visit
waltherarms.com use their dealer locator
all i recommend is look try it
if you're looking at purchasing a
firearm just try the walther pdp run a
google bing
ask jeeves
walther pdp review see if you find a
negative one these are great these are
very well kept secrets because they
don't they don't have the multi-billion
trillion dollar advertising budget as
some of these other companies yeah
absolutely all right now there's a
homeless jeeves with an iphone like
thank you now he's got a flip phone
i don't know hold on i have to type it
in my razor oh
i thought i was gonna be something mom
[Laughter]
okay so uh while talking about china and
look let me just be clear about
something people say what's wrong with
hating something this is when people
talk about hate speech i hate china not
the people the communist chinese
government that oppresses its people so
as a whole
i hate china when people use the term
hate speech you're not supposed to hate
people right as christians you can hate
evil and china the government of china
is evil china's impact on the world is
largely evil so i won't be brow beaten
i don't want to hate speak well they're
jailing muslims and arresting people for
having bibles so you know what i hate it
uh yeah you hate i don't know child
slavery is that something you're not
into that's actually not one of my
primary qualms with china oh gotcha
they do make a i told you not speak for
me they do make everything john cena
wears yes
do you want to pay 200 for nikes do you
dave no you're right no absolutely it
should only be three dollars to make and
400 to buy joke's on you i shop at
payless
29.99 10 years ago
i have my keys yes i bought everything
when they went under
oh they went under yeah where am i
buying my shoes i don't know oh
dave's payload yes oh
that makes i bought an old payless and
didn't change the sign right i don't
walk right for a week
those phones don't make themselves guys
all right
so speaking of which and this is we
talked about this i think she's a
traitor when people talk about the idea
of insurrection i think this is treason
so remember eileen goo oh yeah [ __ ] yes
but she's attractive so she was an
american born skier
remember she decided to ski for china in
the olympics uh yeah she was born in the
united states and this is the problem
with identity politics where it's just
no no it's not about your values it's
not about where you're actually born
it's about you know uh just your race or
certain superficial features we want to
categorize you by that so she decided to
race for china as opposed to the united
states and here is what she had to say
about that decision back then his
refresher
born in san francisco to an american
father and a chinese mother eileen
announced in 2019 that she would ski for
china at the beijing games
the opportunity here for the sport to
grow and to be one of those idols who
really made me who i am as a skier if i
know the impact that they had on me yeah
so she decided she got a you know
she got a contract with victoria's
secret is the chinese girl behind the
white girl we just saw five pictures of
[Music]
i assume so okay i just want to make
sure
hiding behind a mogul yeah skiing on top
of a nuclear reactor at the beijing
games
oh look how we just pick the most
oppressed part of you and you're that
yes exactly
yeah that's just no okay well she picked
the most depressed part of her but then
decided to say hey i want to represent
china really
really here's the thing she never spoke
out against china and their gross abuses
of human rights no no no no um she is
hot now yes i mean i just wanted to
throw that in there because it is
relevant i want you to i want to
i want you to see me as a credible
witness
because if i said she's ugly then you'll
just have to discount everything he said
well it's true yeah
it doesn't mean she's not she's very
attractive and uh very good at skiing
treasonous yes well here's the thing
here's the kicker
to my jail she's back in the united
states you're payless yes goo as she's
uh known that's her that's her nickname
who is her last name she's back in the
united states now and she's decided that
she's going to be an ambassador for salt
lake city's olympic fit so now she's
she's now she's american again oh the us
is going for the winter olympic games in
salt lake city in 2030 trying to get
that host if the olympics are in the u.s
in 2030 any chance you switch to switch
to rsi
it's funny that you mentioned that
because um i am actually an ambassador
for the salt lake city 2030 olympic bid
um and i think that that's this
beautiful example of globalism and bid
yourself a soul we can use schemes and
we can use sport and you can use winter
sport to connect people it's
about
salt lake specifically wants to become a
global destination for athletes
everywhere to come train there and they
want to incorporate 15 new countries
into the winter olympics and i think
that's something that's really beautiful
and i've always wanted to incorporate
you into this really honored to be a
part of the whole thing and we'll see if
it goes ahead now this is all figurative
of course yeah
does she know
why is she allowed to be an ambassador
for the united states for anything yeah
think about that for a second we went
from and by the way this whole idea that
we've always been this incredibly racist
nation even before the civil rights act
think about world war ii was about to go
into the was about to go into the war
front was supposed to be the eastern
front joe lewis the most beloved athlete
in all the united states and he was
fighting max schmeling who was
basically sort of made a de facto
representative of the nazis this was a
huge fight think about let me i've
talked about this before in the past but
for people who don't know let me give
you a little bit of a history lesson
okay joe lewis had the biggest fights
the biggest sporting events that had
ever taken place was black in the 1930s
and the 1940s okay he was beloved by the
united states doesn't mean that there
aren't individual racists i highly
recommend joe lewis's biography it's
incredibly fascinating it shows you the
kind of racism that he encountered in
detroit versus you gave it to me it's a
really good read talked about how he
wasn't referred to as the n word until
he moved to detroit yep he also went was
proud to fight for his country unlike
muhammad ali and instead after he he won
this fight with max schmeling they
decided to make more of an ambassador
for morale for the troops which makes
sense and then afterwards it's also a
great lesson in how the tax man decides
to rape you because joe lewis did a
bunch of exhibition fights to raise
money for i believe it was the troops
for charity and instead they decided
they had to pay taxes on it so we had to
return from retirement so this is what
happens with wartime heroes they're
never really appreciated just like
winston churchill was ousted within two
years because hey fought off the nazis
he didn't want to support socialized
healthcare but i want to give you this
context eileen goo decides to abandon
her country to be a traitor a treasonous
traitor then she decides to ski for
china and now she's ambassador of the
united states joe lewis a black american
beloved was fighting a guy named max
schmeling if you don't know this let's
let's have them pull this clip for mug
club later on uh i don't know if they
have the first fight it might have been
really telling extraordinary story what
he did it really is he is yeah so joe
lewis undefeated okay at this point in
his career he's about to go
to europe world war ii
and he's fighting the only guy to have
beaten him a guy named max schmeling
knocked him out joe lewis hadn't lost
any other fights except for a guy named
max schmelling who is now the
representative of the aryan race so
people know about jesse owens they don't
know about joe lewis versus max melanie
a lot of people don't anyways so he's
about to go into world war ii he's been
drafted hitler's saying look we're going
to show our racial superiority with max
schmeling versus your american and he
didn't say black guy back then he said
american negro we're going to show how
much better we are the americans rallied
behind joe lewis there was so much
pressure on this guy as the
representative of his country the
president called him and said you got to
win this man i don't think there's ever
been a more consequential moment in
sports history but can you imagine if
joe lewis just said oh you know what i'm
going to instead i'm going to uh i'm
going to go fight for uh
china
i'm going to go fight for germany and
then come back and then come back he
would have been absolutely excoriated
rejected by the american public well the
argument that she's making is she's like
i wanted to be an idol for young girls
over there to be able to how about being
a spokesperson they don't have young
girls they drown them in bathtubs
exactly right for their one china policy
that they had i know they've moved on
from that a little bit late but they
wouldn't have even had the chance to ski
over there she was taking advantage of
the united states all of the training
facilities everything and then she left
and by the way if they're skiers in
china they don't get to pick it it's
when they're born they go oh you have
good joy instructor you're a gymnast you
work in coal mine you're a skier you
don't have a choice yeah but even then a
country that was you know arguably much
harder on on a race than
he wouldn't have crossed joe lewis's
mind no no never what's the difference
and you know and you're right it is the
most pivotal moment in sports history
because it made hitler go am i wrong am
i wrong is this all am i wrong with
smelling just a just a just a [ __ ] bar
oh
oh and by the way you should know joe
lewis won that fight knocked out max
schmeling i believe in the first round
cold with a strong right hand well and
then imagine merely shot sure
yeah there's no bigger pressure no
you're fighting the nazis
fist it's insane
it's amazing and now we have someone who
wants to ski for china because you can
get a victoria's secret catalog by the
way chinese women don't need you as an
inspiration do you know what their
inspiration is to be skiers their
government kills their family if they
don't skate yeah it's chosen for them
this is something that this is just how
tone deaf and yes primarily white eileen
goo is you think of in the united states
because women have choices you want to
inspire young women not just to make the
choice to be a skier but inspire them
hopefully to be disciplined to do the
hard work when nobody's paying attention
after the excitement is worn off you
don't need to inspire that in china they
have no choice they get punished they
get their rights removed from them and
their families are punished if they
don't ski for the country
yeah that's why it's 99 perspiration one
percent death threats against your
family yeah with those death threats
they carry a lot of weight the thing
that she could have done was inspire
people to be free yeah to have a
government that allowed them to make
these choices in their life like you
were saying this is just forced and i
think she's mis she's
i don't know that i believe this because
this is the first time and we covered
this story when it came out this is the
first time that she said this this is
the first time that i've heard her say
this maybe let me be a little bit more
clear that this is what she was wanting
to do we looked at it and it was like
she's gonna get millions and millions
and millions of dollars and china
doesn't have dual citizenship no you're
either chinese citizen or you're not
right i don't know how she's not a
chinese citizen right now why is she
allowed back why did we accept her i
assumed that if she's going to be an
ambassador for the assault did you say
salt lake city salt lake city for the
salt lake city united states why is she
allowed to be back she would walk in
like oh yeah oh yeah let me take you to
the uh you know there's we have a we
have a yen room eileen goo it's filled
with yen she just goes in like oh no
it's just the abu ghrai as soon as she
goes in a hood and a german shepherd
barking at her did we say yen room we
meant abu ghraib we're sorry whoops and
this is all oh this is
the video
yes yeah enjoy hope you like torture
unbelievable
instead we accept them back we accept
these people back who rejected their
country and then want to come back for
the milk and honey so if they reflect
globalism yeah to promote globalism
because that's a good idea creepiest
part about it do you want to know what
globalism is okay when she talks about
it and this is a very clear-cut example
right
so seldom do you have people this
blissfully unaware of themselves and
stupid so she's saying globalism she's
talking about china because she's out
for her own self-interest globalism is
having someone right next to you with
festering leprosy sores and saying yeah
i want to link arms with that
do you want leprosy
or do you not well one's globalism and
one says ah you know what we don't want
to link arms with countries that don't
share our values and kill their own
citizens yeah and commit how can you
talk about the united states being
flawed which we are as it relates to
human rights or our history and say i
think globalism is a beautiful thing
hold on are you still bitching about
slavery centuries ago here you know they
still have slaves there right you know
that i don't want to hear you bitching
about [ __ ] that we did 100 years ago or
200 years ago as you profit off of
modern indentured servitude i'm so tired
of this [ __ ] i have i hate china okay i
hate sweden i hate john cena
with the passion now the character right
figuratively literally literally yes but
we were curious about what the chinese
thought regarding eileen goo and so we
actually did send we have more budget
here at ladder with crowder as you can
see by the uh
dynamic outfit we sent our our street
beats crew to xinjiang to uh to find out
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
how do you feel about island goo going
to america
what
yeah you can just go to america
you can just i could just leave china
and go to america is it
no
no eileen goo is a white devil number
one traitor in all of china she is not
welcome in xinjiang and
and she's really not that hot anyway so
i don't even care i hate it
i hate her
finally
dude what take me with you
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
he tried all right
he did i guess it's or the ginger's a
recessive gene even with the asians
by the way share the show right now if
you're watching here on youtube uh you
can share this it apparently helps with
the youtube algorithm now they want you
to share because they want everyone to
go to youtube
they want more people on site for you
know all of these shows that uh youtube
you don't make money off of and then
they ban you yes and they ban us and you
can smash the like button as well too
all these things just help and you know
what that's all you got to do if you
don't join my club just you know go
click it doesn't burn that much
so let's uh we're going to talk about
the border crisis we don't have a lot of
time um
let's talk about uh the housing uh
market not just that but of course that
the fed you know raise their interest
rates but this of course impacts the
housing market um
i want to hear from you what do you
expect you can comment below what you
expect to happen here with the housing
market do you expect to crash
we'll get into why i think there's going
to be a correction but
it won't be exactly like 2008 because
2008 was unprecedented and what we are
dealing with now is unprecedented but
the commonality is they both share
government manipulation uh artificial
either suppression or inflation of
markets
the government never gets it right yeah
so we're going to see this come to a
screeching halt i don't know exactly
what it looks like but you can hold me
to this i said it earlier i'm willing to
if you're looking to buy a house
i'd wait till uh you know late summer
you're going to see a significant change
in price mid 2050 yes mid-2015 just rent
until then let's uh we have a clip that
the fed of course if you don't know they
just raised the interest rates by uh is
it 0.75 yeah oh that's 7.75 last night
the current picture is plain to see
is it the labor market is extremely
tight
and inflation is much too high
ah genius against this backdrop today
the federal open market committee raised
its policy interest rate by three
quarters of a percentage point
and anticipates that ongoing increases
in that rate will be appropriate so
that's the biggest rate uh raised since
1994 yeah and uh it's i think that makes
the current rate about one and a half
percent and some people are actually
projecting a three percent uh interest
rate now
yeah up to a three percent right now
just to be clear i know mortgage rates
aren't just i'm not saying that the fed
rate is a mortgage rate but this does
affect the way banks the way everybody
is able to get loans so it does uh
affect
all of these issues particularly your
relationship with your bank and of
course we've seen mortgage i think the
mortgage rates what is it above i know
it's above six are we at seven years
it's above six i mean this just happened
yesterday so that that rate is going to
continue to go up yeah we're probably
approaching seven percent right now
trump it was around three
uh i understand about two and a half two
and a half yeah yeah very low this is
very in that range now keep in mind
though i will say this this is unpopular
these interest rates should have been
higher on home mortgages for much longer
yeah yeah these look this is
artificially keeping these rates low
which is what people got used to that
isn't necessarily a good thing and the
reason that they're raising these rates
now is because they say oh this is a
problem with inflation well here's let
me explain that brief let me just use
the housing market as an example of
course this affects a lot of issues but
the housing market is an example yeah
what do you think happens when you keep
rates artificially low
right you keep them down at two percent
for example
what happens is they have a bunch of
people purchasing homes that they can't
actually afford they can't actually live
in right at that point it's almost like
well cash is cheap i'm going to purchase
this home it's a no-brainer at that
point as opposed to when the rates
should be actually reflective of the
market which i think we probably should
have been for quite a while six seven
percent assuming you actually get 20 or
30 down well guess what we wouldn't have
the exact same supply issue that we have
now so it's going to change because i'll
get into the supply issues that are
taking place and how you're seeing the
housing market change but a lot of
people don't understand uh these rates
have been kept artificially low for a
significant period of time same thing
this is why you were getting what if you
kept it safe in savings at the bank
we're like oh you want to put in our
savings account oh what kind of interest
do i get well i don't know how familiar
are you with pie it's one tenth of that
yeah exactly yeah
for every hundred thousand dollars you
get three dollars a year yeah good yeah
i'm not even kidding minus our fees you
owe us eighteen dollars yeah yeah here
we go the thing i hate about these guys
is that they always act like they're the
smartest people out there that they are
able to manage the market like nobody
else their stated goal and i know we're
going to talk about in a minute but it's
2 inflation and we've been well above
that for a long time for him to come out
and go inflation is high it's like
yes it has been for a long time and
you've done nothing you've done
absolutely nothing and congress has done
nothing to stop it you've printed more
money you've kept rates artificially low
you know what happens when college the
rates on tuition are kept low because
it's a government-backed program more
people go to college and tuition
skyrockets we know that this happens in
every industry that you do it why would
you expect something different in
housing right which was the last
depression-ish moment this i think in my
opinion this may be worse because a lot
of people have been buying homes where
they've way over bid i mean about 50 100
000
waiving all kinds of uh what do you call
the inspections everything yeah so now
you have that the house the housing
value has nowhere to go but down you
have to refinance you can't because of
the the the rate the rate difference so
now you lose your house who's there to
scoop it up
companies that want to buy it to make a
renter's class and that's exactly what
we're so this is what's different from
2008 so 2008 the housing market look and
and this is also what i love did you see
the big short yeah yeah it's a great
film but they also don't tell you a
portion of it it's and this is why we do
the change my i i hope that this
encourages you
how to think not what to think but how
to think that's why i make all the
references available lightworkcrater.com
you can see the link i think in the
description i think we're putting it on
youtube but you go to livestrutter.com
you'll see all references for every
single show in 2008 what we were
struggling with and they didn't tell you
about this in the big short they just go
predatory lending right yeah wait wait
wait what's predatory hold on a second
let's walk through this how do lenders
banks how do they make money
by people paying it back uh-huh and they
pay it back with interest okay that's
how they make money right what's
predatory lending you're lending to
people who you know can't pay you back
well that's [ __ ] that doesn't make
any sense but they're insured by the
government if people can't pay it back
the government pays it back not to
mention in the form of bailouts when
you're too big to fail which is exactly
what we've deemed
organizations like blackrock i think
vanguard as well so what you had was
people saying oh the rates are low and i
don't have to put any money down because
the government said we need equal
opportunity and housing so yeah i'll get
a half a million dollar house giving you
zero down at two percent then all of a
sudden we hit a recession these people
are living well beyond their means and
there was a record number of defaults
right foreclosures that's what happened
in 2008 yeah a little bit different now
a little bit different now but it's the
same cast of characters right the fed
coming in and saying hey we're going to
help you out they wrote a book about
alan greenspan calling him the maestro
right and saying oh man he was just
playing the markets and the economy he
was the guy who led to those policies he
was the guy that led to that kind of
lending because of how he handled the
rates that led us to 2008 and they're
like oh well maybe barney frank
underground brothel didn't help no well
and in no way a lot of areas were you
know going for double what they were
actually worth and you're seeing that
now right now he's getting very close to
it right and here's what you're seeing
now you are seeing a record number of
people who purchased homes now uh
these prices have been going up for a
few reasons okay you have people who've
been paid to not work effectively right
you have people who've just gone out the
rates have been incredibly low and yes
you combine that with actual wage growth
that we saw under donald trump so you
saw actual wage growth more than ever in
modern modern american history and
unfortunately americans don't say okay
we've seen an average of i think was
five thousand dollars in average salary
wage growth for the average american uh
i don't know if that was the median or
the mean we'll we'll get the reference
up and i always forget but it was about
five thousand dollars in three years
whereas barack obama i believe it was
one thousand dollars yeah over the
course of eight years so they see okay
real wage growth now they don't say let
me be responsible let me take that and
use that appropriately too many
americans say oh that allows me to spend
like i got a 10 or 20 000 increase yeah
they bought homes that they couldn't
afford and now guess what we don't
really have despite them saying we have
a very powerful we have the most robust
i love how the fed and jean-pierre
didn't actually get their uh didn't
actually get their their talking points
together so this is the most robust
economy and job market ever and the
fed's like oh we have a problem with
people in uh
homes and we have a problem with
inflation we better do something hold on
a second you guys hold on the white
house said that inflation was a good
thing so they can't even keep their
stories straight but now you have people
who are very likely to become unemployed
and they're going to have to start
selling these homes because they're
stretched too thin
now
let me give you a couple of numbers here
that are significant so the total unsold
inventory of new houses and what that
means is how many houses are on the
market that haven't been purchased yet
right spike
from march to april by 447
000 available homes that's the highest
month-to-month jump since may 2008. yeah
same deal oh boy so march to april boom
all of a sudden an explosion
like the big shitty debt bang
of homes now available right you were
saying everyone's bidding over value oh
big time that just changed right not in
every municipality but across that is a
huge since may 2008. now here's
something else that people have tried to
present to you they've tried to say oh
actually
it's a supply issue it's a supply issue
as it relates to uh homes there aren't
enough homes for people well that's not
true because we actually have we have a
very high ratio of homes in this country
compared to people who live here yeah
compared to let's say the 1950s compared
to let's say the 1960s 70s 80s right i
don't know what the record number
highest but certainly close it's not a
supply issue it's about people being
encouraged to overbuy irresponsibly
issue and it's also an issue of
blackrock vanguard too big to fail
organizations buying up homes left and
right yeah so that is kind of the
intangible problem yes that's kind of
the intangible here just to be clear we
may not see a full correction if
blackrock these big groups who want you
to never own a home ever just to be
clear yeah they're not looking out for
you
just like john cena's not looking out
for you but what may cause a crash is
let's say you're a vanguard let's say
you're blackrock and you see you know
the stock market doing so poorly and you
go well it's like in real estate may not
be the best investment they may decide
to migrate some of their investments
let's say into i don't know safer safety
fixed incomes whatever it could be i
have no idea but they might just say
it's time to buy low in the market as
opposed to looking at homes right now
this could be a problem so if they
decide to jump ship then you would be
looking at a crash that would make 2008
look like child's play i don't think
we'll fully see that yeah but you will
see a correction and people saying well
i really think i deserve my home did you
put 20 30 down
no then you don't yeah sometimes
sometimes it puts you in a really bad
position when you just go oh i can put
zero percent down on this thing and i
can get in here and i can barely make
the payment but what we really have a
problem with right now is the fed
thinking that they are smarter than the
market right they are the ones turning
the dials in each direction going oh i'm
correcting here and it's really the
federal government as well right so it's
not it doesn't just stop there it's joe
biden it's treasury all that stuff
yelling they keep turning the dials oh
no we're correct here oh my god we
created a problem over here we gotta
correct here and oh my god now they're
thinking like well now we're screwed
right and so people are wondering okay
they raise the interest rate how does
that affect me we're about to tell you
how it affects you it's massive well
mathematically yeah you put 30 down on
something that doubled now it's worth
half so you've technically put 15 down
on the original price right you're
screwed well actually i have those so
let's let's play this conservatively
actually use your point to use some
numbers let's say under trump get a 350
000 home yeah at a 2.5 rate uh your
mortgage would have been somewhere
around 13 1400 a month i think oh that's
right i have it down here i didn't
realize i should i just read
what i wrote 13 13
13.83 a month yeah uh 1382
a month that exact same home under buy
and at a 7 rate which is about where we
are right now would be 23.29 per month
that's almost a 1 000
per month difference yeah so you're now
buying a lot less house than you could
have under donald trump one thing too i
want to make clear is i think we need to
change this language from they're
raising the rates to they can no longer
afford to artificially keep rates low
right yeah no that's that's a better way
of lifting that's very true and put
inflation on top of that and homes
people are spending 350 to 400
more per month so just with inflation
and what the fed is doing right now and
the interest rates that you're seeing
each family is spending 13 to 1400 per
month more with no wage growth joe biden
heading into a recession yeah how does
that sound right how does that sound
heading into the midterms heading into
the election in 2024 this guy's been at
the wheel when he should have had one of
the best economic stories because the
country was opening back up the world
was opening back up he's been at the
wheel less than two years and he's
already screwed everything up this is
the worst president not only in my
lifetime but i asked my in his lifetime
too he said it makes carter look like
chuck i was about to say yeah carter is
like oh thank god for joe biden
now i'm not the worst so keeping i don't
think that we're going to have a
complete food shortage here in the
united states but i will tell you this
prepare for just prepare for
certain uh certain goods to not be
available on the shelves i think we'll
probably run into is look if you're not
really scraping by for groceries if
you're let's say you're living below
your means you'll probably be fine but
for people who can't afford the increase
that's coming it could be catastrophic
and i think maybe one week you might
have a tough time getting beef the next
week you might have a tough time getting
chicken so i'm not saying it's going to
look like soviet russia but if you
combine the fact that people are
spending well over a thousand dollars
more if you're looking at people trying
to get into a home right now at home and
then you look at inflation which is by
their metrics well over eight percent
that's a that's a scary thing that's a
scary thing right now then you look at
supply shortages you look at gas prices
that people are paying so yeah we are
going to see a recession we know that
and i try to not be a doomsday theorist
that's why i've always said you should
be prepared for the worst case scenario
but it's usually not as bad as a lot of
am radio hosts want to tell you right
but i don't want you looking back saying
i couldn't have possibly known that
things were going to get a little tight
they're definitely going to get a little
tight be prepared for it be prepared to
buy low more millionaires are made
during depressions recessions than at
any other point in history so tighten
your belt be responsible now hopefully
you have been responsible up until this
point not living high on the hog like
the rest of these americans who've
overspent and been encouraged to do so
by the government and if you didn't do
it take this as a learning lesson and do
it next time because the market always
ends up correcting itself unfortunately
it doesn't correct itself nearly as
quickly as it has to when the government
decides no no wait hold on a second
that's the market correcting itself
that's not fair uh black people have
enough homes fannie mae freddie mac
frank dodd oh yeah right so
that's not fair we need to make sure
that the banks start doing more
predatory lending which is a term that
only a [ __ ] person could use i'm
sorry spaz
yes
that's so much better oh and by the way
the stock market is below 30 000 right
now down over 700
so you know hey joe biden they're taking
away all those plaques that donald trump
had for every time he got the stock
market up another thousand they're
repointing those right now so yes when
you want to dig into your retirement to
pay off part of your house you're going
to go it's not there right
where to go
again because this government is so
smart are you listening no more plaques
by the way buy and shut your mouth
because we can see your plaque hey
tomorrow in grand junction colorado uh
dave landau is going to be there and
we'll both be in colorado springs this
saturday yes
i don't know that there are any tickets
left for sale online if there are there
are very few but there we've made some
walk-ups available so if you're in
colorado springs get there get there in
the morning just to be clear we're going
to go announce the one of the costume
contests uh youtube
you don't like these costumes you know
what i look
i don't blame you so let's just say that
i've been banned right now for this
outfit because i would take that one
right on the chin and ask for another
youtube piss off
[Music]
you